alors il ya des tonnes de vidéos qui
vous vante les mérites des filtres ndé
comme quoi ça serait indispensable pour
avoir rendu cinéma et là moi moi je dis
stop
enfin vu que je vais vous en parlais
juste après ben je vais vous dire aussi
intro et salut les amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique mans encore ça
fait un mois qu'on s'est pas vu ça fait
un mois qu'il peut une nouvelle vidéo
et franchement je suis super content de
vous retrouver
ça fait vraiment plaisir vous m'avez
manqué je vous expliquerai à la fin de
la vidéo pour ceux que ça intéresse pas
pourquoi j'ai pas été là pendant un mois
mais en tout cas la chaîne elle est
repartie de plus belle pour une nouvelle
saison on va y avoir plein vidéo va se
passer mais plein de choses cette année
ça va être juste dingue mais bon
revenons à nos moutons
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de vous parler
d'un piège dans lequel on peut
facilement tomber c'est celui des
filtres md alors les filtres est mené il
ya beaucoup de chaînes qui vous explique
à quoi ça sert comment s'en servir etc
on va en parler un petit peu aussi mais
moi ce que je voudrais surtout vous dire
c'est que ça n'est absolument pas
indispensable du moins pas tout le temps
il ya moyen de faire sens et absolument
pas quelque chose d'obligatoire
après me faites pas dire ce que j'ai pas
dit non plus il ya des cas où c'est
franchement utile et où ça rend
énormément servi ça on est bien d'accord
c'est donc l'heure de la toute petite
minute et oui où je vais vous expliquer
à quoi sert un filtre années pour faire
très simple un filtre endesa va venir se
visser sur votre objectif et ça va
servir tout simplement de lunettes de
soleil exactement comme celles que vous
pouvez mettre pour atténuer la quantité
de lumière qui va bien frappé le capteur
de votre appareil photo pourquoi est ce
qu'on voudrait atténuer la quantité de
lumière généralement ni plusieurs
lumières plus c'est facile que c'est
simple il faut que la lumière si on n'a
pas assez galère etc
oui oui d'ailleurs en photo c'est très
souvent le cas mais pour la vidéo c'est
un petit peu plus particulier tout
simplement parce qu'en vidéo il est
fortement conseillé de filmer à une
vitesse d'obturation ou shutter speed
fixe pour ça il ya une règle par exemple
si vous filmez à 25 images par seconde
on mettra le shooteur speed à 1 50e si
vous filmez à 100 images par seconde en
mettra à 1 2 centièmes bref vous avez
compris la règle mathématique
bon enfin ça c'est surtout vrai en
lumière artificielle parce qu'on peut
avoir ce qu'on appelle des sentiments si
on règle mal le chanteur speed en
lumière
lurel c'est un petit peu moins vrai le
mouvement peut paraître un petit peu
moins fluide mais on a un petit peu plus
de latitude
mais ça veut donc dire que le shooteur
speed et fixe à 1 50e il est
relativement lent et ça veut dire que
dans des conditions de forte luminosité
on va avoir un truc à peu près comme ça
voilà quelque chose de complètement
surexposé inexploitables inutilisable
dégueulasse bref on pourra rien en faire
du coup tu te dis ben merde alors simon
schoch speedy doit être fixes et que
j'ai un plan sur exposé ses morts cloud
pas filmer a justement c'est là que le
filtre end et va intervenir en posant
ses lunettes de soleil par dessus
l'objectif toujours avec ce shooter fixe
on va pouvoir réduire la quantité de
lumière qui va arriver se retrouver avec
un plan correctement exposée mais mais
mais mais mais c'est pas parce qu'on est
en extérieur en plein après midi qui a
forcément besoin d'un film traîne des et
là c'est le moment où pour prouver mon
point de vue je vais vous montrer un
truc que j'ai filmé en plein après midi
sans aucun filtre md et il ya eu aucun
souci d'exposition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc comment je fais pour me passer de
filtre est né là dessus jean naslin dans
mon sac comment j'ai fait pour ne pas le
sortir pour ne pas avoir à le sortir
pour pouvoir figurer comme ça il ya
plusieurs solutions
déjà je suis mais à 100 images par
secondes ça veut dire que mon chanteur
speed était à 1 200e donc forcément il
est plus rapide il ya moins de lumière
qui rentre et donc j'avais beaucoup
moins de lumière qui arrivait sur nos
capteurs déjà le fait de filmer en slow
motion ou ans en images par secondes
puisque toute façon je voulais faire des
ralentis déjà rien que ça ça va réduire
la quantité de lumière qui varient
ensuite il ya un autre point sur lequel
on peut influer sans forcément modifier
le nombre d'image par seconde c'est tout
simplement l'ouverture du diaphragme de
l'objectif
d'ailleurs je vous ai fait une vidéo qui
s'affiche ici où je parle de flou
d'arrière plan et notamment de ce fameux
le diaphragme et de cette ouverture
le truc c'est que plus l'objectif ou
grand plus il ya de lumière qui rentre
dedans donc on se peut se retrouver avec
notre shooteur fixe toujours avec
quelque chose de surexposer ben je vous
le donne en mille ha il suffit de fermer
un petit peu le diaphragme et on aura
forcément moins de lumière donc on sur
exposera pas il sait pas plus compliqué
que ça pascal situations où on veut une
grande ouverture pour avoir beaucoup de
flou parce qu'on est en très basse
luminosité ou des choses comme ça mais
dans beaucoup de cas en pleine lumière
en plein après midi
est ce qu'on a vraiment besoin d'ouvrir
je sais pas - 8 1 4 on peut très bien
ouverts à f4 avoir quand même du fou
derrière un petit peu moins mais avoir
une très belle image et avoir une zone
de netteté beaucoup plus grandes aussi
pour pouvoir voir beaucoup plus de
choses et pas besoin d'avoir un flou
d'arrière-plan de malades en permanence
et donc il faut surtout pas tomber dans
le piège de se dire que si on est en
plein après-midi systématiquement on va
devoir utiliser un filtre ndé et j'irai
même plus loin
le piège ultime ça serait de mettre ces
iso en automatique je vous explique
pourquoi
admettons à plein après-midi grand
soleil beaucoup de lumière je mets mon
filtre ndé parce que voilà j'estime que
c'est la meilleure chose à faire je veux
quand même du flou et cetera j'estime
comme ça a vite fait la lumière comme
étant trop importante si j'ai laissé mes
ciseaux
en automatique et que je mets mon fils
traîne des jeux là sont gris mon image
l'appareil photo qu'est-ce qu'il va se
dire lui six jamais c'est trop sombre si
finalement c'était pas surexposer il va
se dire oh
l'image est sombre n'y a pas assez de
lumière je vais augmenter les iso et
qu'est ce qui se passe quand les iso ils
montent trop on a du bruit on a une
image dégueulasse on a des plans bosch
vraiment avec avec une image sale ou pas
faire ça pas bien non base pas cool donc
pour résumer le filtre end et il n'est
pas obligatoire pour filmer même dans
des conditions de grande luminosité il
ya toujours des réglages qui vont
pouvoir vous permettre de garder votre
chanteur speed fixe sans avoir une
surexposition on a dit à l'ouverture
on a aussi la possibilité de filmer à un
framerate plus élevé avec plus d'image
par seconde pour faire du slow motion
tout ça ça va permettre de réduire
l'exposition est de se passer de filtres
end est tout simplement parce qu'un bon
filtre ndc à son cou et bah si on n'a
pas forcément le budget sachez qu'il ya
quand même des façons de faire il ya
quand même des façon de filmer
correctement et d'exposer correctement
ce qui n'empêche que je vous dise à moi
j'ai des filtres nv aussi je m'en sers
quand je filme sur 25 images par seconde
enveloppe quand je suis en extérieur
impossible pour moi si je veux food
arrière-plan un minimum parce que je
trouve ça quand même joli c'est
impossible pour moi d'exposer
correctement sans fil trenet c'est bien
d'en avoir un mais c'est pas obligé de
le sortir en permanence et surtout si
vous le sortez à un moment où la
luminosité elle est pas suffisante alors
que vous croyez peut-être que l l'été ça
peut vous donner un fichier complètement
dégueulasse si jamais vous avez laissé
disons en automatique et donc dernier
conseil
un toujours checker sans filtre end et
regarder l'histogramme voir s'il ya des
endroits où ça crame par exemple et la
voir si vous pouvez pas jouer sur
l'ouverture ou en dernier recours mettre
le filtre indé mais pas forcément se
dire qu'on va le mettre systématiquement
je vous le disais au début le filtre nds
est pas synonyme
deux rendus cinématiques ça n'a rien à
voir bien d'accord voilà les amis c'est
tout pour aujourd'hui j'espère que cette
vidéo vous aura été utile j'ai pris
grave de plaisir ça me manquait youtube
c'était voilà la c c'est cool ça repense
ça va être bien cette année vraiment
cool si cette vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner si c'est pas déjà le
cas
on met toujours le traditionnel coup de
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui se
situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo
vous pouvez commenter mais c'est votre
avis pouvez partager la vidéo
aujourd'hui là au moment où je tourne on
a passé les quinze mille abonnés c'est
juste malade 15000 vous êtes 15000 avoir
cliqué sur le bouton s'abonner sais
c'est trop bon et voilà donc c'est super
cool et moi je vous dis bien sûr comme
toujours un serpent partie rester
curieux et à très bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo alors un mois d'absence
c'est parce que tout simplement je vous
avais expliqué je crois que c'était fin
juin ou début juillet que je lançais ma
boîte de prod vidéo voilà et il se
trouve que ça marche super bien que j'ai
pas arrêté de tourner de l'été j'avais
pas du coup pas de temps pour youtube
là ça s'est un petit peu calmé c'est
très bien périodes creuses ça va me
permettre de ne passer plus de temps sur
youtube avec vous mais en tout cas tout
va bien je suis heureux comme jamais et
c'est cool et c'est aussi grâce à mon
quoi c'est grâce à vous je vous fais des
bisous